all right people we are live on rumble
youtube and blaze tv
as always do me a favor subscribe tap
the notification bell etc etc i'm still
dave rubin this is still a reuben report
direct message it is february 15th
2022 i hope you all had a great and love
filled valentine's day canada which we
are going to be focusing on exclusively
today basically uh did not have a great
valentine's day because uh justin
trudeau the prime minister of canada he
basically slapped canada across the face
and said it was for their own good you
know what i mean and that's not how it
works justin and uh i'm gonna take you
down over the course of the next half
hour and i want to give just like a very
special shout out to all of the
canadians who are watching the show i
know we're getting a tremendous amount
of support in canada and i know you guys
appreciate me talking about this story
and we've been talking about it from day
one it was just obvious to me
two three weeks ago when this thing
started that it was going to be
it was going to be the story it really
was going to be the story when the
people the actual people stand up
against the machine that's the only way
this thing gets fixed and in two weeks
what you guys have done is absolutely
extraordinary and
you know there's always a counteraction
right and what justin trudeau has done
really over the last two weeks but then
culminating in what he did yesterday and
which will now obviously
lead us going forward over the next few
weeks and months um is is the perfect
example of why progressives are
everything they purport everyone else to
be and they are not
the rainbow diversity tolerance loving
people they're actually quite horrific
authoritarians but we're going to get
into all of that so obviously we'll talk
about justin trudeau the way the media
is just slandering and lying about the
truckers and doing it
the way they've done it with everything
else the way they've called us all
racists and homophobes and everything
else they're just pushing all of the
nonsense that we can now see through
they're pushing it on to all of the
truckers and now this movement is
spreading worldwide so we're going to
show you video from israel and australia
and new zealand and germany and italy
and a whole bunch of other countries
where a true populist uprising in the
best sense of it that people are coming
together and saying hey we like freedom
we like liberty this has nothing to do
with racism or anything else we've had
it with governments that abuse us and
lock us down and punish us and take away
our rights we've just had enough so
we're going to talk about that then
yesterday afternoon
jordan peterson released the video just
a couple minute video uh with a direct
message to the truckers that i thought
was as eloquent and thoughtful as jordan
usually puts out so we're gonna play
some of that and talk about that and
then we've got a special finish for you
that i'm very very excited about uh
before though we get into any of that
people i want to talk to you about
bonner private wine because if there was
ever a time to drink especially if
you're in canada now is the time do you
know what's in that wine bottle sitting
on your kitchen counter nope traditional
media won't tell you this try oak
flavoring mega purple dye and tons of
sugar and that's not counting all the
chemicals left over from vineyards that
look more like oil refineries than the
great chateaus of old but better wines
do exist and they don't cost an arm and
a leg either take it from america's top
wine explorer recently he came across a
wine unlike anything he's ever tasted
problem is this delicious red wine can
only be found in a single isolated
corridor known as the world's most
remote wine valley heck he nearly died
twice trying to find these vineyards the
wine is that special want to give them a
try today over at bonner private wines
my audience can get these rare wines at
half the retail price no need for a
promo code plus you'll get 50 off
shipping this wine is truly something
special but supplies are limited visit
bonner privatewines.com
dave claim your wine that's bonner
private wines dot com slash dave it's
right here and i knocked out a nice
bottle of malbec the other night with a
tried tip
that would have made you proud uh so
check out modernprivatewise.com all
right so this whole show is devoted to
canada the show is uh not only devoted
this show is dedicated to canada okay we
are with you
good canadians we stand with you canada
against your
authoritarian completely out of control
lying dishonest chill of a man that is
your prime minister justin trudeau so
you all know how this story because
you've been watching this show not
because you've been watching mainstream
media you all know how this began about
two weeks ago a bunch of truckers
decided to do this convoy across the
country to just say hey we've just had
enough of the lockdowns because canada
has had some of the most draconian
lockdowns in all of the west australia's
had some bad ones we've obviously had
some bad ones here in the states in our
blue states specifically but canada has
had really nationwide really awful
lockdowns montreal quebec all over the
place toronto et cetera et cetera so a
bunch of truckers just grassroots came
together a movement of the people hey
let's do this caravan let's get a whole
bunch of us we'll drive across the
country we'll talk about freedom we'll
wave
canadian flags it's going to be great
and that's what they did and it had
nothing to do with hate or anything else
okay
now
justin trudeau
doesn't really like
freedom he's the head of the liberal
party
okay and about a week ago here is what
justin trudeau tweeted about the
truckers he said today in the house
members of parliament unanimously
condemned the anti-semitism
islamophobia
anti-black racism homophobia and
transphobia
that we've seen on display in ottawa
over the past number of days together
let's keep working to make canada more
exclusive now i know i've read this
tweet to you a couple days ago and the
reason that i did it and repeated it
again today is because it's very
important as i've been saying to know
how we got to where we got the steps
that got us there okay so think about
this a bunch of decent people truckers
okay
decent people who just want to live free
they decide to do something to push back
against government overreach right they
didn't do anything violent they didn't
blow up oil refineries they didn't burn
down stores they didn't attack innocent
people or anything of that nature stuff
that you know the media is into if
you're on the right side of the
political aisle they didn't do any of
that stuff they just said hey let's do
this trucker convoy let's get people
waving flags on the streets for us
etcetera etcetera his initial go-to
response because this is all that the
left and progressives have anymore is to
call these people islamophobes
and anti-semites and transphobes i mean
really like if you just really think
about it it's hilarious like it's
actually it doesn't get much funnier
than that like a group of people are
just like hey can i go to work again i'd
like to see grandma you know go to
school no mass it's all good we'll take
a chance we'll live life you know crazy
and then the prime minister says you
have an irrational fear of trans people
and that's why you're doing this you
hate jews and that's why you're doing
this you have an irrational fear of
those homosexuals and that's why you're
getting in your trucks and driving
across the country it's completely
bananas but it has it has actually
worked it has worked on a
disproportionate amount of people it's
completely insane but thankfully
thankfully
because perhaps of these tubes that
people like me can do these shows on and
because you people haven't been
completely bamboozled by these snake oil
salesmen people are waking up people are
waking up and suddenly what started
happening is truckers were going wait a
minute i'm not a transphobe i just
wanted to live freely there might be a
trans trucker out there i don't even
know and then more and more people
started showing up and going to ottawa
and waving flags and kids were out there
and they were cleaning up and they were
doing good things
but
what lies beneath the diversity and
rainbows of a tolerant progressive
is a very angry authoritarian so
yesterday this is when it really got
escalated and trudeau had many chances
to de-escalate okay he had two weeks
worth of time where he could have said
okay we're gonna roll back some of this
stuff but no they never do right we know
these people never do you show them
evidence they double down that's exactly
what justin trudeau did and yesterday he
gave himself emergency power
to continue building on these efforts
the federal government is ready to use
more tools at its disposal to get the
situation fully under control
after discussing
with cabinet and caucus
after consultation with premiers from
all provinces and territories
after speaking with opposition leaders
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations
the emergencies act to address the
blockade and occupations that reminded
me of a speech
from a while back it is with great
reluctance
that i have agreed to this calling
i love democracy
i love the republic
the power you give me i will lay down
when this crisis has awakened
see what we did there ah that's all
connor people okay so you can see what's
happening here trudeau
is now pulling a palpatine right you
create the crisis because it's your
lockdowns that create the crisis just
like palpatine created the uh the trade
embargo on naboo i don't want to get
into all of that with the droids and the
viceroy of the trade federation and all
that you obviously know about that stuff
but pal he's literally doing a palpatine
okay and then what you do is as the
crisis gets ramped up the things that
you say are temporary actually don't
become temporary they become permanent
and then you have to ramp up the ways
that you're going to punish people so
trudeau continued here's how the
measures we're taking today
will help get the situation under
control
the police will be given more tools to
restore order in places where public
assemblies can constitute illegal and
dangerous activities such as blockades
and occupations as seen in ottawa the
ambassador bridge and
elsewhere these tools include
strengthening their ability to impose
fines
or imprisonment
the government will designate secure and
protect places and infrastructure that
are critical to our economy and people's
jobs including border crossings and
airports
we cannot and will not
allow illegal
and dangerous activities to continue
the emergencies act will also allow the
government to make sure essential
services are rendered for example in
order to tow vehicles blocking roads
in addition financial institutions will
be authorized or directed to render
essential services to help address the
situation including by regulating and
prohibiting the use of property to fund
or support illegal blockades
okay so let's be clear again
very clear and careful with our words
this protest which is an organized
protest from the bottom up a grassroots
protest has been completely peaceful
they have not vandalized they have not
destroyed property they have done what
you are supposed to do in a western
society when you feel that your rights
are being encroached on that they've
done it
perfectly to the t almost in at a
completely extraordinary and and almost
untenable way they've done it because
it's very hard to do something so
peacefully and have it not hijacked by
radicals and everything else but you can
see now he's going to arrest people
we're going to find people
more police etc etc and that also
reminded me of a speech by that
palpatine guy
in order to ensure the security and
continuing responsibility
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like my whole life led me to
today's show just
really feeling it um it gets worse it
actually gets worse um now let's put the
joking part aside for just a second uh
trudeau's deputy prime minister her
name's christia christia freeland
uh she has now gotten in on this and
they are going to ramp up
stopping people from crowdfunding
because obviously the truckers have been
crowdfunding first on gofundme then
gofundme shut them down even though
gofundme had no problem uh supporting
black lives matter while they were
burning down american cities everywhere
so then there was another website called
gibbs and go which is a christian
website
that allows for crowdfunding and the
government has had it with them so now
they're going to look at these people
who are crowdfunding under the terrorist
financing act
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money
laundering and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
okay do you see the incredible
escalation that just took place because
this is this is seriously scary stuff
because when we see say police cracking
down on peaceful protesters right so
you're out there peacefully protesting
i've got a canadian flag i love canada i
love poutine i'm free i want to live
freely john candy rick moranis stan
akroyd love all these people love canada
uh and then they were to punch you in
the face which we've seen some of that
by the canadian police it's obvious
right it's right in our face oh my god
good guys bad guys it's very clear what
they are now doing is something much
more nefarious because they're basically
saying if you aren't involved in this if
you
uh donate to one of these crowdfunding
sites if you figure out a way that you
can send them cryptos so that they can
peacefully protest maybe so they have
access to gas as they're driving across
the country fuel etc etc
we are going to come after not only the
crowdfunding websites which
gofundme just voluntarily just cut them
off
but we're going to come after the
crowdfunding websites and we're going to
go after the people that are trading
crypto now first off i don't think that
these clowns in the canadian government
really understand what crypto is an
entirely decentralized payment system i
mean
crypto is designed to stand up against
centralized power so i think they've
unearthed something here they just
opened the pandora's box we're going to
stop you guys from trading crypto oh
well crypto's totally decentralized and
people are trading peer-to-peer and uh
it has nothing to do with you guys and
pretty much you can't stop us so they've
opened up something here that's a huge
mess and and thank god that crypto
gotten got
developed the way it did over the last
decade it was basically for this very
moment when a centralized authoritarian
government would go completely out of
control and try to take down peaceful
protesters okay so this is this is
seriously
bad news and what it really is about of
course is to scare people right because
as i said if you just send the troops
out on the streets and you beat people
it becomes obvious right it's too
obvious for even the average person boy
they shouldn't be beating those old
women and kids and then you might push
more people to your side so what they're
really trying to do here is by saying
we're going to go after you
cryptocurrency people who are going to
go after you crowdfunders is they're
just trying to send the signal across
the galaxy of fear that that's what
they're trying to reverberate throughout
the galaxy fear fear fear fear there
should just be fear everywhere so that
you'll be so that you know if you want
to trade crypto the way people trade
crypto
on the super bowl there was a freaking
coinbase ad people trade crypto people
are trying to figure out ways to get off
the rails that are clearly not working
the way they're supposed to anymore
but they want to send a message we're
watching you
we're watching you guys we know you're
up to bad news what do you think you are
you think you can just live freely in a
free society
we're canadian government here we know
what's good for you uh i had a tweet on
this that went pretty viral yesterday so
we thought we'd throw it up for you real
quick because i think it kind of
captures in twitter form what's going on
here we are witnessing the progressive
revolution eat itself this is the
beginning of the end of a petty tyrant
who came into power by preaching
diversity in rainbows what lies beneath
that facade is much darker and dangerous
the world might be saved by canadian
truckers uh i don't need to pat myself
on the back for a viral tweet but i
think it sort of captures this idea that
these people come in with all of the
diversity and love and trudeau loves the
lgbtq i forgot all the letters what are
the letters again okay
they come in with this and he looks nice
and he talks about all the right things
but then once push comes to shove once
the rubber meets the road you see what
they do what they become and they become
it overnight and it's obvious and until
enough of us are no longer fooled by it
until enough of us are actually willing
to pull back the curtain and realize
that the guy standing there is an old
wizard not some or he's an old you know
snake oil salesman not some big green
wizard with all power uh then the game
will continue it will just continue and
one of the ways the game continues is
because the media the corporate press
the mainstream media just lies to us
about everything so when when it's their
guys burning down the cities and
destroying best buys and targets and pep
boys and whatever else those are the
good guys and we should be tolerant of
it but when it's peaceful people you
know protesting for freedom they're bad
guys they're right-wing maniacs
alt-right
et cetera
here's mr potato head himself brian
stelter over on c
n
n
i was just googling that old quote from
jon stewart mill he talked about your
rights and where my nose begins so like
your freedom sometimes infringes on
others freedom and i think donal what
you've seen in in canada is others are
fearful of these protesters who are
arguing for freedom right because of
some of the french rhetoric can we play
the daily show clip for a second this
was you appearing on the daily show and
then trevor noah had a reaction
and because you're not vaccinated have
you
is there businesses there stuff you
can't do in canada now
yeah like i'm like i'm like well
basically if you want to compare canada
uh to anything it's like uh hitler's
germany
and we're like the jews eh
you see this is why we shouldn't be
banning books
[Laughter]
i can't say it better than trevor noah
yeah look and i mean there is that
that's a really big part of what we're
seeing there and and the re that just
doesn't come from anywhere right because
that that that that terrible historical
inaccurate comparison uh we've heard
members of congress here repeated but
it's actually i think a lot of it is
based in there's been so much
demonization of public health officials
in this country and elsewhere right um
that a lot of these people
believe that public health officials are
there to harm and hurt them not to help
them right it's the bigger picture here
is online radicalization
of lots of different kinds turns into
offline action and whether there end up
being convoys in the us or not we're
already seeing the impacts of that in
canada i feel like that's your beat
dhoni is it's the online radicalization
but then you see what happens in real in
in real life
i i just said to my guys as we were
playing this it's truly incredible
watching these people flip the story and
how they reverse everything they say
about one thing when it's their guys
doing it versus how uh they say it when
it's the other guys doing it first off i
just want to say something very very
clearly here um i i lost family members
on both sides of the holocaust okay i
grew up around holocaust survivors i am
well versed in what the holocaust was
and what the demonization of people is
um although
the guy who was interviewed there and by
the way great cherry picking on that
daily show and then they they
cherry-picked that on the daily show
and then of course they throw that to
cnn because they're all in on it
together i believe they're both owned by
viacom it's just one big circle jerk in
essence um
just
regardless of what the guy said whether
whether you think he said it in a
butchered way or or he shouldn't say it
or something like that
the way something like the holocaust
starts is you otherwise people right you
keep otherizing otherizing them you say
oh you can't be part of the economy you
can't own a store you can't do this
we're going to demonize you you're
diseased
so it is not a giant leap okay it really
is not and i don't care how much hate i
get for this it is not a giant leap
after two years of demonizing certain
people who wanted choice medical choice
and choice used to be thought of as a
good thing
to compare them to the jews before the
holocaust it's not a perfectly
symmetrical
situation right there aren't gas
chambers in canada yet
okay so it's not perfect but it is not
deeply wrong and the message behind what
he said
the message behind what he said was
basically right so stelter laughs at it
and and
trevor noah who has a series of highly
we covered it last week highly offensive
jokes if you get offended by jokes
towards jews who's now trying to destroy
joe rogan uh you know he's this is why
you know we shouldn't burn books okay
fine
but this is what they do this is what
they do this is brian stelter who as
the cities in america burned he excused
it this is what they did on cnn they
constantly excused it so now we oh and
and then the guy that he's sitting with
there uh this o'donnell guy you know
this is because of the rhetoric or
whatever well stelter you started the
segment by saying that your rights end
where my nose begins except these
truckers haven't punched anybody they
haven't done anything violent they've
done it peacefully they've protested
exactly the way that john stuart mill
one of the great classical liberal
thinkers of all time the architects of
classical liberalism the architects the
architect of some of the ideas that led
to this great nation right they did it
exactly the way you're supposed to do it
because they're not burning buildings
they're not punching people they're not
attacking people they're using words
they're using words and they're right to
protest which are classically liberal
values which are liberal which are
values of a western democracy so still
to everything there that stelter said
there the whole segment you have to
admire the evil of the way they trick
people into thinking that those people
did anything bad it's incredible but it
continues with this clown this absolute
clown man thomas friedman of the new
york times if you want to just like in
the dictionary guy who gets everything
wrong always but keeps his job here's
thomas friedman they're going to
consider fines and even potentially
taking away some of these trucks i mean
this this gets to the heart of a pretty
big problem at this point
you know becky we right now we have a
pandemic of the foolish and the selfish
um you know what are the governments in
america and canada asking of these
drivers who cross borders back and forth
every day is get quarantined get
vaccinated fully vaccinated or or be
quarantined do it for yourself do it for
your neighbors most of all do it for the
doctors and nurses who have been
completely exhausted after two years of
this um so you won't be putting
additional pressure on them uh and so i
i find all this all being done in the
name of freedom
freedom from who from mother nature
freedom from you [ __ ] we've had
it with you people we've had it i cannot
stand these people anymore i ca i don't
okay this is the pandemic of the foolish
and selfish really thomas friedman how
about you show me a study on how many
how much covert was spread by truckers
driving alone in their trucks
moving all the products across the
country keeping the economy going can
you show me a study on that no you can't
but underneath every single one of these
leftist lunatics is the
worst sort of authoritarian ever
what is it what are they talking about
you're foolish and selfish
for demanding that you be allowed to
live as you wish to live so that you can
go visit grandma and your kids can go to
school without masks and everything else
two years after two weeks to flatten the
curve
god these people are just this protest
is stupid and selfish
stupid and selfish really thomas
friedman you awful
bad man bad bad man
but from one bad man here's a bad woman
this is governor gretchen whitmer
from michigan this is the woman who
locked down michigan in the worst sort
of awful ways who literally at the
beginning of all of this
did not want people to do gardening in
their front lawns yes actually true and
i sent i mentioned it on the show and
then i started sending people we had
people email us and i sent people seeds
i did so people could garden and people
sent me back pictures of their gardens
in michigan because of this crazy
psychopath well she's not happy with
these truckers either governor whitmer
i'm sorry i was asking you about this
encouragement uh by the right-wing media
of this blockade
well it's dangerous they're inciting and
encouraging people to break the law and
to do so in a way that devastates so
many hard-working people this is
families this is businesses in america
that rely on this commerce
free-flowing
lady has the botox gone to your brain
that you can't even hear yourself
anymore
you're now suddenly concerned about the
economy and people's ability to work and
put food on the table and all of those
things you people are the ones that
locked everyone down and destroyed the
economy do you not get it can we throw
the video up here again i am not kidding
oh yeah okay there's gretchen whitner
now i don't care if anyone's done work i
don't care if you have injections i
don't care what you do but that woman is
so full of botox that it is obvious to
me that she got botox and all sorts of
stuff when they were locking people down
and they were you know making sure that
people couldn't get medical procedures
and anything else i will give i kid you
not five thousand dollars five thousand
dollars to a doctor who will come
forward and admit that they injected her
with botox or fillers during the
lockdowns because these people are evil
she was also caught as she was locking
everybody down she was caught
on a boat because it was her husband's
birthday and she could do it but you
people can't they hate you they hate you
these awful creatures lizard people
that's what they are
more proof well
don't worry guys when when blm is
burning cities when antifa is burning
cities when cities are burning because
there's an orange man in charge or
something like that then it's all good
it's all good i want to be clear in how
i characterize this this is a mostly a
protest
it is not
it is not generally speaking unruly that
ain't a riot what we're seeing right now
in minneapolis is they are strictly
principled anti-fascists and they've
taken a principle stand to stand against
white supremacists and white
nationalists wherever they may show up i
argue to you tonight all punches
are not equal
morally it says it right in the name
antifa anti fascism which is what they
were there um fighting listen there's
you know no organization is perfect
there was some violence any reasonable
person would say we shouldn't be
destroying other people's property but
these are not reasonable times thank
goodness for the looters man and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite and peaceful i
don't care that much about
statues respectfully shouldn't that be
done by a commission or the city council
not a mob in the middle of the night
throwing it into the harlem we'll do
what they do you're seeing behind me is
one of multiple locations that have been
burning in kenosha wisconsin do not get
it twisted and think that oh this is
some
something that has not never happened
before and then this is so terrible and
where are we in these savages and all of
that this is how this country was
started people get mad and people get
sick of it people are risking covid to
explain to this country that we're fed
up most of the major movements in
american history have started at the
grassroots level and at some point have
turned into direct conflict with
american government so
remember your history before you judge
your president sluggishness is
thuggishness wherever it comes from
politically and we should be the first
to call it out i disagree
dare i quote chris cuobo
but remember your history
remember that history that i just showed
you remember that those people excuse
violence those people
actually instigate violence they tell
people
you're allowed to do it when you think
you should do it now ironically there
are no buildings burning yet in canada
there are no people being assaulted on
the street yet in canada it isn't
because of the truckers that businesses
are closed et cetera et cetera actually
there's many videos of business owners
in ottawa like holy cow people are out
on the streets again i can sell falafel
it's pretty great
the extraordinary lies i don't know how
they do it i don't know how they do it
but we are now going to stop them we
will stop them we will stop them this is
the moment to stop them if there's ever
a moment this is it and guess what
people all over the world are waking up
so now we got just an awesome array of
videos all over the world
of freedom
convoys breaking out everywhere here's
israel first the left loves israel don't
they now they're really going to love
israel
[Music]
[Music]
oh
let me go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
so to be very clear i mean new zealand
new zealand definitely wins for like
coolest protesters uh but what you saw
there were israel germany france
australia italy new zealand this is
obviously going on in canada i have a
sense that maybe it's going to start in
the united states and some of the blue
states as well
but
notice there was nothing burning in the
background
there was no looting
there were no signs to kill trans people
or whatever it is that justin trudeau
has been lying about these are just
people like you
that's what they are you person watching
this right now if any of the stuff that
i talk about here means anything to you
then those people are fighting for you
and they're fighting for you now all
over the globe and it is absolutely
incredible so now we've got some video
we'll bring it back to canada for a
second this is of brian peckford he is
the last living signer of canada's
charter of rights and freedoms the last
living one he gave an
absolutely i mean just a moving
like actually sit back and watch this
speech it's just incredible we're not
going to allow this nation on the
northern part
of north america to go down the drain
because we have people who've gotten
hungry for power and have discarded the
individual freedoms that you and i own
[Music]
[Applause]
they are ours
there's none two of us the same that's
why individual rights and freedoms are
so important right because it's you as a
person
you as an individual not you as a family
not you as a group
okay not you as part of some other
organization not you as part of the
province it's you as an individual
canadian possess these rights
that's what's important
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i recommend you find the the full speech
if you haven't seen the full speech you
can find it on youtube and on rumble i'm
sure
um it's you it's you you get it it's you
that can fix this what if we all have
more power than they want us to think we
have i suspect that we do
and that's why they want to arrest these
good people and find these good people
and make sure that they can't crowdfund
because they fear the individual because
you know what happens when the
individual looks out for themselves the
individual finds other people who look
out for themselves and then you've got
two individuals and they kind of got
some stuff in common and they might
start building something and it might be
good and it might not need them
and i think we've all had enough of them
okay so that's what we're going to keep
doing we're going to keep pushing on
this and keep pushing on it and keep
pushing on it but that being said
this could get out of control right
there's there is definite uh well
there's definitely signs that we're at a
very precarious moment right now right
the government of canada
is now calling these emergency powers
and you know that once the government
goes with emergency powers it doesn't
give those powers away quite easily
so jordan peterson who of course is from
canada okay jordan peterson was a
professor at the university of toronto
for many many years he was born in
western canada i mean he's a true son of
canada and then became the most
influential you know public intellectual
on the globe uh he gave a little video
did about a three minute video
right before trudeau announced the
emergency powers and he talked about
this precarious moment we're in because
you know when you start making getting
somewhere right as the truckers did they
did it right they started getting
somewhere so some of the restrictions
were being pulled back well then some
people start walking away
maybe the radicals double down
the government reaction et cetera et
cetera so jordan put out sort of a basic
warning for where we're at at the moment
and again i just want to reiterate this
was done before a few hours before
trudeau came out with his emergency
power speech
i've been asked to say a few words to
the truckers in ottawa
and so i've given that some careful
consideration
all you protesters
you've accomplished an awful lot already
you know the conservative leadership has
crumbled and
aaron o'toole has been replaced by
someone who is giving a fair bit of
voice to your concerns
you now have a voice in the house of
commons all the people you represent
have a voice in the house of commons you
have four provinces that have moved
quite precipitously
in the direction that the protest was
hoping for starting to lift mass
mandates on something approximating as
reasonable a timeline as might be
expected under the circumstances i'd
like to commend all of you for your
diligence and
and work on
accomplishing what you have accomplished
under
under trying conditions and also
for keeping your heads in a way that's
actually being a
model for the entire world the fact that
you've been able to remain peaceful you
haven't taken the bait you haven't
responded with violence to
quite remarkable denigration and
provocation that's
a sign of tremendous discipline and care
it's going to get more difficult to
maintain as this goes along
so i hope that you're all in this
position to
allow
a sufficient victory to be sufficient
to move forward without grandcore
to
be
grateful for the effect that you've
already had in the support that you've
received
and to
move forward to a normative peace and
the re-establishment of our
country's economy and our
psychological and social well-being
so
that's pretty much all i have to say at
this
point thank you
i mean first off there's just nobody
better you know careful with his words
sober
optimistic realistic
clear all of the stuff i am
jordan if you're watching today i am
truly honored to call you a friend and
and someone
that let me uh join the ride for a year
and a half when we toured together um i
wanted to bring up one specific point
that he brought there and again this was
before justin trudeau ramped this all up
he said it's going to get more difficult
you have to allow for a sufficient
victory
and that's what was happening
until trudeau ramped everything up right
there were premiers in
alberta and some of the other provinces
who were saying we played the videos on
the show here you saw it over the last
couple days that we're saying we're
going to scale back on some of this
stuff we hear you we know you're
frustrated they were even saying we know
you guys have done this peacefully and
you've protested properly we're going to
you know reverse course on some of this
crazy lockdown stuff and the mandate
stuff so they were getting their victory
and then what jordan was saying to them
was now that you've gotten some measure
of victory you have to be careful uh
because you know some of you the the
same more marginal people involved are
going to go away but the people who
really believe in the cause they're
going to continue in essence that's
where things can get um you know
radicalized et cetera et cetera so there
was a really interesting moment there
and it's and that is an important piece
of this right regardless of what side
you're on it's like when you get some
victories you have to know you got a
victory and you have to be gracious for
that so i think that was happening
it's actually that's not that i think it
was happening it was happening we know
they were getting victories and then the
question was well how do you take that
victory and move forward now the problem
is that just as some victories were
happening just as
say a true healing was on the horizon
like oh we protested properly in a
western democracy the government heard
us and they're going to scale back on
the stuff that we're protesting then
trudeau just stepped in it because about
two hours after jordan posted that video
trudeau says he needs emergency powers
and he's going to arrest protesters and
they are going to find people out on the
streets and they are going to come after
your bank accounts and they're going to
go after the crowdfunders etc etc so now
trudeau is the one who just poured
gasoline on the fire so i i will
actually message i'll text jordan right
after this and see if maybe he'll put
one of those messages up directly to
justin trudeau and stare directly in the
camera and say justin trudeau
well you almost had victory to some
degree not victory for justin trudeau
because he wants ultimate power that's
that's what sits beneath these people
but justin trudeau had an off ramp there
really was a way that we weren't going
to be in the situation we were in today
that's what jordan was laying out there
like take your victory
like sit with it for a little while guys
go go i got something and it was good
and and let's go home for a little bit
or or let's keep the pressure on but
like let's acknowledge that there was a
chance that was justin trudeau's
off-ramp they were giving it to him the
other premieres by saying we're going to
scale back some of this stuff but then
he just went all in and that's what they
do with everything
that's what the left and progressives
and whatever remains of the liberal
structure that has been decimated
over the last decade or whatever it is
they double down on everything and that
was always the danger i mean watch my
videos literally guys from six years ago
why was i screaming about all of this as
someone on the left when i was a bernie
supporter saying we can't call everybody
racist we can't call them all bigots and
homophobes and transphobes and all of
those things because once you do that
they're they're the ultimate enemy
they're the ultimate evil and you never
have to look in the mirror and that's
what trudeau has gone with how can
trudeau possibly put an olive branch out
to the homophobes and the racists and
the bigots
i guess he could do it while he's in
blackface if he has any sense of irony
that might be one way to do it
finally guys i thought we would end with
this because this has all been about
truckers right this has all been about
truckers mack trucks big trucks
and i'm a i'm a
child of the 80s and i'm someone who
enjoys the truck and uh something spoke
to me there was a message that kept
resonating and i thought i've heard this
message about freedom i've heard it
before
from a great truck
there are young species
they have much to learn
but i've seen goodness in them
freedom is the light of all sentient
beings
choice is yours people
optimus prime
or justin trudeau
guys if you want to play along live chat
with us during the show you can always
do that by joining
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with charlie kirk from turning
point usa is up on youtube and rumble
today it's already up full ad-free on
locals
that's a show
justin trudeau
we ain't done with you yet see you guys